the course Luthor is named after any
closer every director was a German
mathematician she lives from actually
write down her to use she lived from
1882 to 1935 now this was one of the
golden periods of the development of
mathematics particularly in Germany
there's lots of one thing I love about
that is that so much of it is global
right like we just take for granted the
name Pythagoras or something that
everyone learns and everyone's supposed
to learn and we just kind of could
easily get wait a second why on earth do
we spend time thinking about some
ancient Greek guy sketchies ago or some
german mathematician and what she
achieved okay it's because mathematics
is a universal language right it doesn't
matter whether you're speaking it in it
should create or German or English or
whatever it happens to be
what did she mainly contribute to making
sure he did soot air is interesting to
us firstly she contributed vehicle index
a lot of people in that 1800 1900 well
even now if you have any interest in
physics you have to be interested in
mathematics I don't know how many of you
are thinking at all even sort of
considering doing physics next year real
physics is basically mathematics in an
applied context right it gave up motion
in objects Laurie this is the first
thing and the second thing was algebra
any line algebra are just pretty simple
what'swhat's the 30 and are wonderful
about algebra I encourage you to go and
look up every directed story it's pretty
music but I'm just going to describe one
kind of object that Luther our pioneer
and they're called feels okay so
underneath here especially with also hey
and Jesus
now this is the first year first
introduction to what okay we're not in I
can't see more beyond sir a mathematical
object that you may never encounter even
all the way through a highest level of
high school mathematics and even if you
go to uni you could do a lot of
mathematics which without never without
ever really encountering these objects
or needing to know what they are that's
not to say D joint appointment it's to
say how big the mathematical universe is
it's a little bit like who's traveled
overseas just on a holiday like not to
going to be the family like on a holiday
holiday where did you go America yeah
how have you spend there ten days okay
now let me just ask all of you even if
you've been to the US or not we all know
enough about that place that you can
probably tell me how much of the u.s. do
you think you would experience in ten
days
how much of us would you get a pretty
comprehensive experience on it not even
close
right like you're just scratching the
surface I bet by the time you're that
you're like what we're going already
there's so many things I haven't seen
yet that's the way it is in that Mattox
except even more so right you can stay
here spelling this and there are still
cool things you haven't encountered let
me describe what a field is for you okay
first let's think about it step you guys
have heard of sets before right what is
your set could anyone give me a
description or a definition what is a
set
yeah
a group of objects that perfect a group
of objects it can be a group of any
object we tend to describe set or write
set out with a set of curly braces like
this and we might say okay what what the
certain objects just there's a set of
objects okay one of the things that
characterizes our set is that the order
doesn't matter just put them sort of
energy just with large I bar would be
the same as I've adjusted as opposed to
as a crystal mention before a sequence
the word sequence implies is the set
which has what added all to it it's
things are in sequence if they're
sequential that means there's order
right three to one is not the same
sequence as one two three but it says to
okay now we're a mathematics class right
now so what might be a set in
mathematics this is not really a plug
into the sort of method exhibit not
really okay what might be a mathematical
set what you think escape you
okay so these are all fine these are all
what we call finite sets right because
there is a limited number of objective
but there are infinite sets to origin
let's go without adjusting them leave
one two three dot dot dot
so this is an infinite set okay how
would you describe if you have to give
that set a name what would you call this
set it's a number one it goes on forever
so it's incident but I can make another
infinite set like this and each of sets
are different right what characteristic
find all these numbers together at say
for example maybe different to this set
over here on the suggests doesn't win
okay yeah so there is there's a
different kind of pattern of these are
both original what I want to point out
ok these are sets what it doesn't really
matter so I could say this one looks
like that as well and what's good me the
same set I've just rearranged a little
bit what I'm getting out here is this is
the set of counting numbers we also call
them the natural numbers okay
so this is a set yeah this is not the
set of curly numbers is it right it got
wee bits in between
okay this is the way this is not the way
normal people count this is the way that
the Avery Parent Council they say I'm
going to count to three two and a half
two or three quarters okay miss
something different right
so this is the set of turtleman's okay
so now we understand what this is so
just contender
a field a field is a special kind of set
feel is a set we're going to define its
work with in a minute consider all right
now better better late than never time I
take one of these reading the pizza
played during a garret where reference
point ha I was mid definition okay a
field is a set where operations and the
specific operations we're going to talk
about honor plus - whoops times goodbye
ok now you know I think ok I know a said
is and I know what operations are if a
theaters are set with operations what
would even mean for a field severe
offside not view for a set to not have
operations once I set without operations
what kind of set is that well I've
already got one on the board the very
first one that I wrote down this is a
set set which you can't really do any of
these operations of this I hope not
I'll take any of these objectives like
what is rise divided by unabomb I don't
know what that is okay doesn't really
have a sensible meaning yeah unless you
think about the better so this is a set
um this set here you might think that
you can do plus/minus plans divine on
them but actually you can't
7:23 the set of counting numbers okay I
can choose to add any of the objects in
this set they're actually called
elements and you will get back something
that's in the set
do you agree you can add up any of them
you'll be fine okay but you can't
subtract any of them from any of them
and still be inside the set in fact you
can just look at the three that I've put
on there you can think of a pretty easy
way to
do a subtraction and the answer you get
out is not something that belongs to
that set can someone give me an example
yes three one take away three actually
won't take away anything in this set and
your stuff because now you're not in the
counting numbers anymore you're in the
negative numbers you sort of working out
okay so therefore you can't do these
operations I haven't gone two times and
division it's the same thing here bad
way
multiplication fine but what's the
problem is you're going to introduce
decimals fractions percentages all that
kind of thing and none of them are in
this set of counting numbers okay so I
will tell you what some of the fields
are being are the numbers that look like
this and try to go to best way to write
it
this is a very particular way of writing
not the set of counting numbers but the
set of rational numbers rational numbers
now there's actually something missing
here it's actually goes in the opposite
direction as well because rationals can
be negative two do you see how the set
of rational numbers is a field it's not
just a set it's a field because no
matter what pair of rational numbers you
add or subtract or multiply or divide
you get back another rational number
does that make sense so this is a field
it's more than just a set you can do
more special thing sir how's your brain
doing at the moment these are weird
ideas they're quiet do you see what I
mean by them being sort of off on the
side but what is helping you know do
your products in fact this section in
the cat one on Monday better maybe even
maybe not it will just this is cool and
interesting stuff okay and this is the
sort of thing that Emmy Noether
pioneered and why she's actually called
the probably the most important female
mathematician of all
just kind of a big deal okay